Okay, everybody, come on. Picture time in
front of the tree. Let's go.
Oh, God. Just be quiet.
There you are. Okay. Where's Dylan?
Aw, mom.
No, we need somebody to take the picture.\
Harsh.
What was that?
Don't we always have the fire on?
No!
I'm sure we do. Last year we use it to finish cooking Claire's turkey pieces.
Jay, go turn it on.
Wait wait. Wait wait. Every- Everybody 12 and under
out.
What?
Honey, uh, what's going on?
Dylan's stuck in the chimney.
Oh, why?
He's dressed up as Santa. He was going to
hand presents out to the kids. Oh.
Don't tell them now. I want to be with you.
Tell us what?
Nothing. It can wait.
No! It can't. Please,
my organs are shutting down.
Okay, fine, I-
We have an announcement.
Dylan and I are having a baby.
Are they smiling?
You're pregnant?
Yes. And we're really happy about it.
Why wouldn't you be?
Wow.
Mom.
It's it's a lot to process at once and-
A baby! Unbelievable.
Oh, congratulations.
Oh my gosh, a baby.
Oh, God.
You handled that a lot better than I did back
in the day.
Outside. On the inside, I'm you.
Can somebody saved my life?
Oh, Cam, grab a foot.
Yep. Oh, he's really wedged in there.
If only we had some kind of award winning
placenta based lubricant.
Fine. Here.
Dylan, use a little bit of this.
I can't believe a little Dylan is gonna pop
out of you. What would that even look like?
Oh, now I know.
Hey, everybody, come on in for the picture.
Timer.
This is all gonna work out, right?
Right here.
Definitely. Yeah.
Hang on. Let me get my
elbows ready.
Okay. Everybody smile. Say, baby.
Baby.